luffy isn't strong enough yet to become
pirate king as we now know there is
still a level above what he's currently
capable of that goes for his devil fruit
the voice of all things but most
importantly for his hockey abilities
there are still new and even more
incredible powers for luffy to unlock
and master before he can claim the
throne of the pirate world and liberate
it the final power-ups he will get
before the end of the story and ati
raora the author of one piece has just
revealed what some of these powers are
now saying that luffy still isn't
powerful enough might admittedly sound
like a quite bold statement after he
just took out the strongest creature in
the world ah just one second as you can
probably tell a lot of blood sweat and
tears flow into making a video like this
maybe you have thought about creating
content before but the thought of making
a video scared you well my friends mr
telexify has come up with a solution for
just that and created edited dot tv it's
a platform where you can hire an editor
who's worked with successful creators
that specifically understand how to add
it for the youtube algorithm and create
viral contents and if you sign up for
the premium service for 25 bucks a month
you get unlimited orders on the website
and no transaction fees so go check it
out using the link in the description
kaido was physically the strongest
emperor among the original yonko with an
incredible devil fruit power and next
level hockey let's be real and luffy
managed to defeat him in a one versus
one battle so what's the problem really
well as you well know this fight says
very little about the enemies that are
still to come kaido's title of the
strongest creature conveniently ignores
two types of people those he has never
even fought before and those who have
just recently become stronger than him
luffy of course falling into that latter
category someone else who just recently
has surpassed kaido at least as far as
we know is luffy's arc nemesis marshall
d teach i'm sure you agree that when
luffy will inevitably face blackbeard at
some point in the story it will be an
even harder battle for our straw hats
than the beast pirates i mean blackbeard
not only has two of the most powerful
devil fruits ever in his possession the
darkness fruit and the earthquake fruit
but he also has been building an army of
the strongest and most notorious pirates
of this era feeding all of them powerful
devil fruits in other words luffy right
now would probably not be able to take
on blackbeard similarly i think it's
fair to argue that someone like akainu
is also not going to be an easy win for
luffy right now i've discussed this in
more detail in my video on the enemies
that luffy still has to face but luffy
getting a chance to fight zakazuki and
getting revenge for his brother's death
is almost guaranteed to happen at some
point in the story and he's sure to pose
a real threat to anyone who would want
to fight him one versus one and then of
course there is the man the myth the
red-haired legend himself
shanks has shown us over and over again
that while he doesn't wield a devil
fruit power himself hockey wise he is on
a completely different level from kaido
as well and that already brings us to
the first major power up that luffy will
get now that wano is finally over and
for that i will also be getting into
some of the details revealed in the
special one-piece volume 4 billion that
was distributed for the release of film
reds it's not related to the movie
itself really but the info revealed
about shanks is legitimately canon and
it's probably more than we have ever
learned about shanks's true power in the
regular story itself so shanks's
conqueror's hockey is the strongest in
the story we already pretty much knew
that much since his legendary encounter
with whitebeards not only did anyone
outside of the top brass of whitebeard's
man faint remember those are men who
have been sailing around the new world
and are well accustomed to its dangers
but simply shanks's presence there
damages the mobby dick whitebeard's
flagship physically the planks literally
crack under the pressure of his will and
this is shang's coming for a peaceful
chat mind you in other words this is
just his default mode luffy himself
finally learned about the true potential
of conquerors haki during his fight with
kaido he finally figured out how to use
it for fighting you can code yourself
and your attacks in conquest haki to
deal devastating blows or defend
yourself against your opponent's attacks
in other words it's pretty much what
made kaido and big mom almost
indestructible the user's kingly will
manifest physically which is why we see
the sky split whenever two yonko meet
this explains why whitebeard ship also
took physical damage however shanks
takes all of this to the completely next
level his aura seems to be significantly
larger than that of luffy hokkaido if it
affects people in objects in a radius of
5 meters wherever he goes and most
terrifyingly if you see him anywhere
like right now and you are not
subscribed to this channel he will drink
all your booze true story but chang's
isn't just passively oozing his conquest
hockey he has complete control over it
like no other character in the story
really as he impressively demonstrated
during his drive-by of wano when
ryokugyu was coming for luffy's head and
facing off against momo and the
scabbards shanks was able to identify
aramaki's precise location out of all
the people on wano at that moment and
direct an ultra precise burst of his
haki towards him across many miles from
outside the country's borders in fact
shanks's conqueror's haki was so
powerful that it paralyzed and scared
aramaki forcing him to withdraw from
wano let me repeat that shanks used his
haki long range to scare off a marine
admiral who had just proven his
terrifying strength that is a whole
level above luffy's and kaido's pay
grade at the moment and it gets even
crazier because we've now learned about
two other of shanks's abilities from the
special volume 4 billion that i guess is
probably named after his bouncy shanks
has mastered an ability called kim
bungorushi referring to observation haki
was in japanese is kanbun shokuhaki and
goroshi simply means killing in other
words ken bungoroshi is literally
observation hockey killing it's a
technique that allows shanks to use his
conquest haki to prevent his opponent
from using future sights which is of
course a complete game changer up to now
in any fight it was always a question of
who has the strongest hockey really
however suddenly we know that it's
possible to actually nullify another
person's hockey using conquerors and i
mean as you've probably also just
thought about that means that someone
like katakuri who has mastered his
observation haki would pretty much be
helpless against someone like shanks
completely robbed of his biggest
strength i mean especially for someone
who has integrated such an ability into
his fighting style it must come as a
complete shock to suddenly not be able
to rely on your most potent ability
anymore and let's not forget that luffy
himself also relies quite a bit on
future sight in his fights as well at
this point but that's not all cause oda
sensei has also revealed that shanks is
able to code his sword griffon in a
fiery aura whenever he fights against
his opponents and we do know for a fact
that neither shanks nor any of his men
have eaten a devil fruit so correct me
if i'm wrong please but to me that
sounds like either one of two things
either shanks's sword has eaten the
devil food itself which would be pretty
sick i guess as well or or shanks is
able to generate flames with his hockey
i mean what does that remind you of
exactly luffy's mysterious firepowers
that he uses with red hog and red rock
and so suddenly in one sweeping go
shanks has opened up an entire
new level of power and fighting
abilities in one piece to us and as you
well know luffy won't be able to become
pirate king without reaching at least
the same level as well no matter if
shanks is actually chasing the one piece
himself or whether he will simply test
luffy's power i made a whole video on
that as well if you want to watch that
reaching this level of mastery over his
congress hockey will be a must for luffy
now that he's moving towards the final
islands but of course hockey isn't the
only thing that our captain still has
room to grow in there are still a bunch
of other power-ups waiting for us as
well like with luffy's devil fruit for
instance yes luffy has just awakened his
fruit and used his gear 5 for the first
time which he himself actually called
his pinnacle however luffy's devil fruit
awakening was active for in simply a
couple of minutes at most at the peak of
his fight with kaido and so i think it's
very fair to say that luffy has not
mastered the true potential of the nika
devil fruit quite yet what we saw him do
with it yes was incredibly impressive
absolutely but i think that there must
be more to its true power and potential
for the gorosei to want to erase it from
history the ability to shape its
surroundings and the fact that luffy has
been revealed to be a zone fruit just
opened up so many possibilities what
exactly is gear 5 even is it nika fruit
awakening is it simply luffy's
transformation into the animal slash
nika what does his hybrid form look like
as you can see there are still so many
unanswered questions and things that we
don't know yet about the nika fruit and
luffy himself doesn't even know yet that
he is a zone fruit user and so once he
finds out he will be able to do so much
more with it than right now i think we
really only have seen the beginning of
what this fruit is truly capable of and
why it plays such an important role in
taking down the world government and
changing the world then of course there
is the voice of all things this power is
still incredibly mysterious and seems to
be even rarer than having conquest
hockey luffy so far has only been using
it in a very limited way is able to
detect people's true feelings and
intentions and is able to communicate
with animals which don't get me wrong is
a pretty big deal but there must be more
to this mysterious power as well that
might well be related to the d-clan
itself since roger already was able to
use it we do know for example that roger
was able to understand the polar glyphs
to a certain degree at least using this
ability as well so what other things is
it capable of doing it might actually be
the key to finding and using the one
piece kind of like the secret ability of
the d-clan and let's of course not
forget the ancient weapons as well we
know that poseidon pluton and uranus are
all connected to joy boy and the void
century all three are powerful enough to
destroy the worlds terrible weapons that
can be used for either good or bad but
in the end it sounds like luffy will be
needing them in some way or form in
order to fulfill his dream and create a
new world where everyone is free to live
a happy life these three weapons are
truly mysterious however we might
already know what their secret is and
how they will work these weapons might
actually be much more complex and
sophisticated than we all could have
ever dreamed they seem to include
genetic engineering gigantius monsters
and colossal vessels and if you really
want to learn how they might work you
really should not skip this video right
here